uh y single yeah yeah we [__] no uh not
any porn star we ever had on the show me
neither but other porn got chemistry
with some of them bro so it's like plug
talk but you just lie about [__]
stuite talk we plug in flashlight that's
it we're getting farm league porns [__]
porns yes farm league ask me yes it's
good [__] crazy good crazy mouth game
insane LeBron dude she literally takes
my seam and goes it's crazy
it's insane this poor s had sex with she
put her back on the bed and leaned over
like a rainbow like that we start he
doesn't know what's happening right I
know I got it that's crazy to start
there is crazy how did you end just like
hugging or something you got to go
backwards